foreign
hey everybody what the [__] is this
thing doing in there yeah what is that
what how did that get like that where is
oh it's in front of the camera yeah oh
okay
all right somebody must been [__]
around there's some weird [__] I mean up
here yeah she probably was she crawls
around here when I'm not looking all the
time look up in that damn line through
me like I got a damn Omen oh [__] what
if you like go outside and like some
[__] falls off the top of a seat belt
yeah like like a man in half that [__]
me up just to served I think you
that [__] me up when I was a kid I was
like oh yeah because it was just like an
accident you know you're like you could
be walking around like I know it was the
devil like in the context of the movie
but accidental devil The Accidental
devil yeah so uh so yeah so this episode
here uh we watched it last night and
then Tom just now like watched it again
I watched it again it's still hard to
follow yeah okay so that's this one is
from season four and it's called spirits
of the Dead
and I had kind of remembered this one
because I remembered it took place on a
horse farm
and you know you worked on a horse farm
for a long time so we were kind of like
a bunch of them yeah you've worked on a
bunch of horses yeah so I was so I kind
of remembered it for that but I had
forgotten that unlike most of the other
episodes of Haunting this one for
whatever reason is like the timeline is
all muddled like they kind of I was
gonna say it's muddy yeah like they tell
the story in like a really weird order
and I'm not really sure like why they
chose to do it that way yeah and it's
not I would not call this a compelling
episode although the case is kind of
interesting just the way that they tell
it kind of makes it boring
like I said and it just and it was kind
of vague and like unclear
yeah and you know
um noun usually because I always write
down you pretty much the first thing I
write down when we start watching the
episode I write in the episode name like
the number you know the season and the
number of it the people's names you know
where it took place and what year it
took place they didn't say what year
this happened
did they no
I mean because I would have written it
down they said where it was they did a
good job of skirting around skirting
around facts
to place this in a place and well in a
time yeah because they did say where it
was they did say it was in Kingston New
Hampshire yeah just when this when this
was happening but they didn't say what
they would just say things like
the boy got in the very beginning got
attacked but they don't really specify
what that meant
I don't even remember if they showed it
he just saw something right
yeah I kind of want to get into that
because this like I said this is very um
this episode was like really unclear
because I was having a hard time like
taking notes and like I I started
watching it and it jumped into like some
[__] like it seemed like it jumped ahead
I was like did I miss something like
that I thought it skipped yeah it was
the same thing and so I went like I
turned it off and I backed it up I'm
like no they just started with that even
though that doesn't happen until later I
don't really get like why very difficult
to follow this episode it was yeah and
and I'm not sure exactly what happened
they blessed it and it went away that's
how it ended well no no it kind of went
away
that's it well I mean really there's
only one of two outcomes of these shows
it's like they either bless the [__] and
it goes away and everything has the
smell of sanctity yeah or
they have to like run out the house and
move away right
and this one I think left it ambiguous
I think they pretty much said that it
that it they went off the [__] and it
went okay I mean I thought that's what
they said but like you said it was very
it's unclear not not real clear this one
um but yeah so but I had kind of
remembered this one we hadn't covered
this one so I was like okay well this is
a good one to do because we're still
there's still some season four ones we
haven't talked about
so this one is about I don't know what
year this took place because they don't
say but it does take place in Kingston
New Hampshire apparently
and the couple at the center of it are
named Jim and Joanne Whitley I think
they said Whitley was their last name
and they're both really on there uh Jim
I put at the very end of the notes I
said Jim has a Mario stash because I
kept calling him yeah like that mustache
was [__] uh it was I don't know if it
was epic or if it was an Abomination it
looked like it was greased it looked
like he greased it down or maybe it was
just the way the resolution on the DVD
the way it worked out it was funny
looking funny looking on DVD the texture
looked funny almost like it was painted
on
it's almost like Luigi or something
that's what I said I started like Mario
like Mario yeah that's because I kept
like I kept making jokes like throughout
the whole thing like every time he was
on I was like shouldn't you be fighting
Donkey Kong yeah
I was looking at it was that real is
that a real is that a real mustache but
I think it just might have been a
resolution on the DVD and the way it
looked on HDTV it just it was you know
sometimes a
sometimes the the image doesn't come
across real well it looked like it had
been waxed it was like it was like it
was real wet and waxed and greasy kind
of yeah like to hold it in place maybe
it was it was weird for sure yeah but
like yeah I kept calling him Mario like
throughout the whole thing what are you
talking about Mario look it was painted
on with spray paint it first
say it just for matter or what was that
[__] that uh was it was it Hair Club for
Ben or remember that remember back in
the 80s or nine years this spray on hair
yeah they had that infomercial yeah it
was probably just spray paint like no
yeah
it was basically the same thing that
comes out of like you know you know uh
canned snow like when you're yeah yeah
spraying on the Christmas tree except
dark it's just dark and it would [__]
get into your hair and make like [__]
like Crystal [__] and hide your hide
your bald spot and then they said well
you can brush it and it'll be okay
I never saw it in real life but I looked
at it I was like that does not work
there's no way no way to be able to
brush it I mean without it I mean if
it'll fall out like I said it would
probably just look like you had really
bad dandruff yeah
something bad he and England said the
same stuff Steve segali uses for hair
yeah yeah that's probably what this
dude's yeah was made of he uses shoe
polish I mean hey
[Laughter]
like every little kid dressing up as a
hobo for Halloween she follows you
that's what that's what this Burns a
cork and like rubs it up Steve's skull
at Steve's Gall here that unbelievable
hairline
this shit's [__] razor sharp razor
sharp hairline
well I mean he is committed to like you
know yeah just drawing it on there with
her with a sharpie no he puts tape on
his [__] face that [__] I feel like
that blue painters yeah that blue
painters tape
see we got here
nobody knows yeah nobody knows okay man
oh my God yeah so you see look how we
get off on tanges just because we were
talking about this dude's mustache it's
like it was kind of cool but it's like I
don't know like I said he looked like a
he kind of looked like Mario or or Luigi
I guess the Mario Luigi both kind of he
looked exactly the same their faces look
the same they just had like different
colors red and green yeah and they said
different color outfits yeah so yeah so
Jim and Joanne Whitley that's the couple
um I kind of laughed because the uh the
narrator at the beginning said Joanne is
farm girl tough and so I wrote that down
because that made me laugh
um she said she started working on farms
uh since she was nine years old yeah so
they have a son named David I don't
think they said how old he was he looked
about 12-ish something like that I don't
know maybe a little bit younger
so their big dream was they have been
wanting to open like a horse farm like
you know where they would board people's
horses and they would like you know
train people to ride and [__] like that
because that's what uh Joanne's been
doing her whole life and then this they
kind of like started with that like in
the first minute or two
and then all of a sudden they jumped
right to their son David getting in a
really bad bicycle accident and they
didn't really they just kind of like
glossed over how it happened yeah and so
like he was riding along like riding the
dirt it looked like I don't know how he
got so hurt but I don't so I don't know
so it's like he falls off the bike and
he somehow broke his back like he broke
his spine right and so so they jumped
right into that and I was like wait what
the [__] just happened I was like did I
did it skip ahead because somebody I
mean the discs are old so sometimes like
you know they because I've played them
on my laptop and sometimes I think they
cut some out during the edit but yeah so
I don't so I was like what the [__] and
then so I backed it up I'm like nope
that's okay so they get into that later
but this like I said the timeline of
this is very muddled like the bicycle
accident actually happens later in the
actual timeline but they just started
out with it and I don't really get it so
the kid has to go to the hospital
obviously and they think oh well maybe
he's gonna be paralyzed or he has
permanent spinal spinal damage or
whatever spinal damage
I'm obey a [__] yeah I'm sober I
promise but it's like I've been up since
5am so it's like you know what I mean
I'm a little bit tongue-tied uh but yeah
oh they also mentioned that Jim and
Jimmy had been married for 20 years at
this point but like I said I don't know
what year this was so yeah so David's
back is broken but they said well you
kind of lucked out because yeah his back
is broken and that's bad but um they
said it's not broken in a way that it
won't heal up so it's like eventually
maybe like with a lot of therapy he
should be able to like recover and you
should be able to walk again so he does
he does end up doing that
um and actually they talked to he was on
there wasn't he like as a grown person
obviously I think he was on there for a
couple of minutes like they interviewed
him yeah
so um so yeah so they started out with
this with the bicycle accident and the
kid breaking his back and then they
segue into oh well paranormal stuff has
been going on at this farm for like
years I'm like like what like you know
what I mean it's like they just went
right and I was like okay well you
should have maybe LED with that and then
built up to the bicycle accident it just
like I said it seemed like I don't
remember another episode of a haunting
that was structured this way and I'm not
really entirely sure if they were like
experimenting with the new format or
they were like oh well the bicycle
accident that was like a big deal like
the kid broke his back so let's start
with that because it's like super
exciting but I don't know I kind of feel
like they should have built up to that
instead of starting out with it and then
being like Oh by the way we've had all
this paranormal [__] happening and we
think maybe the bicycle accident was
maybe caused by a ghost or something I
don't know so uh so I didn't really get
it but yeah yeah I didn't think it's
paranormal well that's what I mean it's
like it didn't necessarily A lot of the
things on this are don't seem all that
paranormal like but just sickness
happens with the horses in the barn it's
just I've never seen this before and I
came from a big old bar and I said no a
lot of bad [__] can go wrong in a barn
I've seen [__] go wrong at a bar I also
seen just bad
strings of luck happen in a bar sickness
and injury all happening in a couple
months period if you have enough horses
in there and it's just unusual like an
unusual spike in it but it's not
paranormal it's just chance yeah that's
what I mean it's like you know the thing
about it is that there's there's
something called what is it called the
law of large numbers or something like
that it's like given enough incidences
of something you're gonna have anomalies
and it seems weird but it's like it's
just you know that's just uh what
happens that doesn't mean it's like
Paranormal you know what I mean yeah
you're gonna get like little anomalies
and spikes and things but uh but yeah so
they don't really go into what exactly
this Paranormal Activity was that they
had been experiencing prior to this
bicycle accident but whatever it was
um Joanne was like yeah I'm gonna good
with psychic because I'm kind of sick of
this [__] right so she goes to a psychic
now the first psychic she goes to was
like yeah that's above my pay grade I'm
like not doing that [__] but um she's
like I don't think I can help you
and then she gives her the number of
another woman who
works with energy I think that's what
they said she was like a Shambhala
practitioner yeah bollocks
that's even like Gordon Ramsay says
that's a great word actually yeah her
name is her name was like Sue Bernier is
that what they said her name was I wrote
it down but it's my handwriting is
working with writing in the dark working
with energy
yeah she's an electrician yeah well I
forgot to mention that Jim the husband
on this isn't it yeah energy worker
she's an energy worker yeah yeah
she basically just goes and waves her
hands around it yeah says she's doing
some [__] uh so apparently before so she
talks to Joanne now before sue the
Shambhala the shambolic woman that's
what we're just gonna call her shambolic
Zoo before she goes out to the barn even
or the farm
uh she said that she got like Visions
about the place and like she felt nausea
and shortness of breath and things like
that like she was freaking out about
like going there like before she even
went to the property so but she's like
well I'm gonna come out the next day and
see what I can see and see what I can do
for you
so they said that when she was driving
out there the next day she said that her
big thing is that she can always sense
people
I don't know if she did she say that she
said she sensed them but she could she
like see them they made you think she
could say it seemed like she kind of I
don't know if she implied that she could
see them they kept showing shots of her
walking around in a barn and they never
seeing silhouettes of people inside the
store see it like a Native American guy
like running through the woods yeah she
saw that yeah but she didn't say she
actually saw
ghosts in the barn they just show her
supposedly seeing ghosts in the barn
right you know what I mean but you don't
know if she's just feeling their
presence
or if she's actually seeing because she
never comes out to say it says they do
that a lot on this the narrator never
says she saw the image of the man it
never says anything right so you just
have to there's no I I think the move I
think I think this was there's a couple
things they did see things levitating
yeah
so it's not the case isn't totally
devoid of actual reports of paranormal
phenomena it's just the way the story is
structured and the way things are shown
is difficult to know
what is actual and what's implied
and a lot of their I I feel like a lot
of their reports were kind of nebulous
yeah like the stuff that they said and I
don't know if that was just because they
were being cagey or because it was
edited out or what you know it might
have been a pretty long script they had
to edit down for TV I always wonder
about that because it's like obviously
they interview the people for a long
time and because they need all that
information to do the you know
reenactments yeah but you know so they
cut down you know to just like a few
minutes really but so you don't really
know like what they actually said and
what they actually saw and what they
actually saw because sometimes they'll
put some [__] in the reenactment but
it's like well the person didn't say
that but did they say it in a part of
the interview that they cut out or they
might show a ghost in the background the
person walking around looking spooked
out did they actually see the ghost or
were they just said man I feel like I
was being watched I kind of feel like
they usually do that because what I get
that because that's like a wave you have
to like show it visually yeah it's just
like have somebody walk around going ooh
like that that won't like come across
but they don't come out say you know
yeah I feel like I was being watched you
know what I mean that was to clarify it
you know yeah in a lot of the
a lot of The Haunting episodes are like
that not all of them the real good ones
they
they make it a little a lot more clear
you know but some of the ones are kind
of some of these are kind of vague yes
they're open to interpretation oh yeah
big time yeah Danny Rowling said the
psychic brunette chick in this episode
was in the Attic episode and played the
sister yeah that's right I thought she
looks familiar uh she's a pretty good
actress in my opinion yeah she was
actually really good uh most of the
haunting series especially the early
series The the early Seasons they had
good acting yeah they did yeah they were
good good it's a good series I would
always argue just like as as far as
these kind of like Supernatural shows or
even like horror movies or scary things
in general I always feel like actors in
horror movies and ghost stories and
stuff don't get enough credit yeah
because I kind of feel like acting in a
horror movie is like harder than other
genres yeah and some of the regulars you
know you see the same casts over and
over again as it went on you could tell
they were having fun with this [__]
because you could see him kind of having
it up yeah but it was it was good you
know what I mean like the where's that
raccoon guy you see him a couple times
you see that same woman that cute skinny
woman all the time she she's in like
seven or eight of them she play in all
different kinds of role in it and
sometimes he's the psychic sometimes
she's the girl that got haunted and some
she eventually started Hamming it up but
it was still good acting yeah I yeah I
always liked her yeah you know you know
exactly what I'm talking about yeah I
know you don't yeah by the way
home there you go I didn't expect yeah
did you well I mean you said it so I was
like that's the best commercial
s
Victor says I got my cookbook thanks
guys oh yeah oh yeah that's right I
forgot a lot about that you enjoyed it
yeah hopefully you like it
hopefully it's up met your expectations
Zach says some of the best acting I've
ever seen is in horror and thrillers
yeah exactly like hereditary Fatal
Attraction for example yeah and that's
what that's I'm still mad that like Tony
Collette didn't even get an Oscar Nam
for [__] hereditary because she was
incredible in that well because the
thing about horror is that the whole
thing is you have to adequately portray
not only heightened emotions but you
have to make the audience believe
unbelievable [__] and that's hard like
if you're just in a drama or something
like that where it's like realistic I
feel I'm not saying that that's not hard
too but it's like I don't think it's as
hard as conveying a really believable
Terror and stuff like that like you
would have to do in a horror movie so I
think it's harder I think I've seen
hereditary heredity hereditary I guess I
think I've seen it three times
I didn't like it in the theater I fell
asleep during it
and we saw it in the house and I warmed
up to it because we own it and then I
think we saw the third time and I liked
it a lot better on the third time I
thought you'd only seen it two times
maybe okay then then because I've only
seen it two times because the first time
I saw it it [__] me up really bad and
I really wanted to see it again but I
was like I kind of did I guess that was
the second time I saw it but then I
finally did like watch it again I like
mid-summer saw that in the theater and
we owned that one I liked it from this
time I think we saw that twice in the
theater yeah I like that one yeah yeah I
like about it yeah ariaster he's awesome
yeah
he did the lighthouse too yeah my one of
my favorite new actresses in it Florence
peel yeah that girl her she's got a cute
head I like it she's adorable I like her
big head well she's been in like some
newer [__] that we probably should see
wasn't she isn't she in don't worry
darling has anybody seen that yet I've
heard really mixed reviews about like it
sounded cool like I saw um a trailer but
I was just kind of like I don't know I
might end up watching I also liked her
and fighting with my family it's a fun
Florida movie about Paige the wrestler
Paige she did a great job in that I love
it and I got the extended version on
Blu-ray it's longer it's good real good
I want to see that one again I also want
to see uh the uh
uh Mark what's his name movie [__]
was it pain again painting gate yeah she
knew exactly what I'm thinking yeah
exactly I've known you a long time I own
it on Blu-ray [__] Victor says don't
worry darling it's definitely worth the
watch
um what I said about don't worry darling
Florence Pew was in that um because I
like I said I'd heard a lot about it but
I heard the kind of like mixed reviews
but he said it's definitely worth a
watch she's British isn't she yes I'll
tell you man she's a good actress all
the best actors and actresses are coming
from England
they got better standards
she's great though I like her yeah I
like her too yeah she just comes across
as likable too just seeing her like yeah
something you can hang out with bro yeah
that's yeah that and that definitely
comes across yeah
but um okay so let's get let's get back
to this first yeah okay so um
so yeah what were we talking about the
[__] is shambolic Zoo yeah
I'm just
but yeah so
um so she says that she like I said she
feels like she senses people and can
like sense their moods and have felt how
they died and blah blah
and then so here's the thing so sue and
Joanne are walking around the farm and
Joanne is like relating
all of this stuff to sue like all this
crazy [__] that's been going on so then
they like go back in time like I said
this is a very convoluted way of going
above telling this story I don't really
know why they felt the need to do that
but so she had so they actually go back
in time and they said yeah me and Jim
like the Mario the husband with the
stash
I said we bought the farm they bought
the farm
um after it had been abandoned for a
really long time they said it was it's
300 acres so it's not an insignificant
chunk of change they said they got a
good deal on it but
um you know it had been abandoned for a
long time so it was a it was a mess they
said it was a mess but they knew that
they could do something with it so I
guess like Joanne has been a horse
trainer which is that's what your mom
does she basically does the same thing
around us
um and Jim is an electrician so they're
like okay well we can figure all this
out we'll fix it all up so over the next
year they kind of renovate the place and
start to open up the business so like I
said their their whole thing is that I
mean I guess Jim's like goes out to work
like as a contractor like electrician
and stuff but Joanne she boards people's
horses and like trains people to ride
like and or to um to go into like
competition you know what I mean like
horse jumping and stuff like that so
like I said that's what that's what his
mom does yeah I could do it too though
for well yeah children and novice you
know I got experience with that too I
was doing that at like [__] 12 13.
training other children and [__] yeah
just
I grew up in that in that industry and
it's just
it's kind of a whole scene like a lot of
things are like all the competitions and
people travel around and like to be
shopping to me of a second nature
because I had to learn it because of who
my mom was it really wasn't me yeah so
I'm never really driven to do it but I
can ride I can jump [__] my
equitation is good it's all English
um never got into into dressage or
anything but just Hunter jumper stuff
you know what I mean it was just
it's just
they're not as fast as motorcycles and
horses don't always obey that's the
problem well yeah because they're kind
of they're they're all they have their
own they're very good if you're in the
[__] situation there's no fuel it's
like post-apocalyptic Special Forces as
good with horses or they were and camels
um but you know
it's just kind of second nature started
off with ponies and then thoroughbreds
and [__] but it was never really my
choice
it was always just kind of like a family
well like I said you got raised in it
and your mom did it and that was like
her business and so you always like
worked at farms and like took care of
horses and stuff yeah in between any
kind of military or Contracting type
work I was doing that that was good and
I actually prefer working in kitchens to
that
which some people [__] hate kitchens
but I like cooking I work in the kitchen
that's [__] hard work I mean it is
yeah but um
it's just I'm just so burnt out on
[__] the horse scene I I just you
know I don't care well I mean when I met
you you were working yeah at a farm yeah
like is that a stable yeah at a stable I
take care of horses which like I said
was the same kind of that I don't think
they did any training there but they
boarded people's horses yeah and they
had a bunch of their own too
um actually that was like the second or
third one I was at in this area you're
talking about Dr Matt's Place yeah yeah
yeah there's a
famous kind of well famous in the
medical scene Rich doctor he came from a
[__] family of doctors his mom built
with Orlando general hospital with a
bunch of donations and [__] and he runs
the hospital down in uh Samford no not
Stanford uh Altamont he runs that
hospital so he just hires doctors and
[__] teams and doctors and [__] and I
took care of his
bar all right had about eight horses
there it was beautiful private barn on
us on an estate out yeah it was nice
hidden not that far from our old house
actually right just like a mile or sale
back where we were doing the show from
before it was yeah five mile five six
miles from there a beautiful mansion and
it was like like an amusement but you go
in there it's like something out of
Disney white fences everywhere in
pastures and a big old plantation house
and next to it I think it was a 10 stall
barn with wash racks and tack room with
it was air conditioned and it was like
an office and beautiful you know
and it was his family members and
Friends of the family that stayed there
I took it they'd go off to Egypt and go
to [__] other countries and I'd take
care of that place for
months on end sometimes yeah because
they were gone a lot yeah
and uh you know just did security there
and [__] grounds keeping and took
care of horses and just held the
chickens and chickens and goats goats
they had goats yeah
the turkey yeah the turkey died under my
watch but it was old it was gonna die
they had an awesome goat yeah named
Franklin Franklin yeah they had more
than one goo but Franklin was awesome he
had a damn
facility there to [__] rebuild
Cadillacs he and his son he would get
these old 50s Cadillacs and rebuild them
but they had a couple of them there but
they they didn't do it while I was there
I think I did that I think I was with
him for about 18 months two years I
think it was a while yeah because like I
said I when I met you you were doing
that and you did that for like a long
time yeah
he was a good dude he was a good dude
but Dr Matt was a good dude very
generous
um very wealthy from a very uh powerful
Jewish American family in the medical
industry
so uh so yeah so Joanne's walking around
this big 300 Acre Farm telling shambolic
Zoo what is what's been going on
so she says when they first opened the
barn or the farm like to borders and
then students and stuff
um the lights in the barn she said kept
going on and off by themselves like all
the time and I guess she sort of also
implied that some of the students like
didn't like it there like they thought
it was kind of creepy or they thought it
was creepy at least that the lights were
going on and off
and so Joanne complains about it to Jim
her husband and he says look I have
wired that Barn myself there's really no
because like I said he's an electrician
so it's like there's no way that there
could be anything wrong but I'll check
it anyway
so the next morning he goes out there
and checks it all and he's like look I
can't find a single thing wrong with it
you know it's just got to be a fluke or
something like that so they just kind of
write it off however when Jim is
checking the electrical this particular
morning he said that he heard kids
playing and he's like you know they only
had one kid and I guess the kid wasn't
around there was like no one else around
it's a 300 acre property so he said he
heard kids playing and it weirded him
out but he just kind of like wrote it
off as you'll see Jim was kind of like
he and he seemed a little bit like this
still even though I guess he'd finally
come to accept what was happening but he
definitely seemed like one of those
um oh you're crazy [__] you
know what I mean like he's kind of like
laughing at her his wife and everything
because she was always complaining about
stuff like hearing things and whatnot
so but he did hear some [__] too but he
just kind of pretended he didn't
now apparently Joanne's business like
started doing well right away uh so she
gets like a lot of students a lot of
borders and she's like training students
like for competition and stuff like that
and some of them help out around the
farm as well now they uh she has a bunch
of horses of her own as well as boarding
some from students but her favorite one
is named uh Frisco
and she said that Frisco started acting
really strangely like he didn't want to
eat or drink and he was just like acting
really uneasy they said like a lot of
the horses were acting kind of uneasy
but she was like the most upset about
Frisco because because she was her
favorite horse but and so she like not
eating and stuff
so
um one day like while there was other
people at the farm like the kid was
there and the dad was there and
everything like that she's in the house
and she said that she heard
she said it sounded like a herd of
horses like Galloping past the house
so she thought as you would that all of
the horses had got out of the stable
somehow well hello did you see her
little head Pokemon she's trying to get
a tangent hello
um but yeah so she thought well all the
horses had escaped from the barn so she
runs out and she's like did you guys
hear that it's like did all the horses
get out like what happened and they all
look at her like she's a nutcase because
they're like no all the horses are in
here it's fine and you know and her
husband is just kind of like no we
didn't hear anything it's you're just
imagining things obviously there's a
girl in there saying imagine Tom and
those uh sexy ass tight dressage they
were actually called Marlboros in an ear
you don't have to imagine you don't have
to imagine you don't have to imagine I'm
wearing Marlboros right there
oh black outfit right there with a
little goth jacket on and uh some some
of the sometimes I had to go ride
people's horses because they'd be gone
for too long
okay you gotta ride them keep them in
good shape ride and jump them
but uh no it's a low res pitcher but
that's that's me and that's not it Dr
Matt's place that's at the place before
I was working for Dr Matt that was where
minaleta lived before you oh right where
are you that's not far from the biker
bar yeah I was gonna say that's like
here in Sorrento right yep that's not
far from here yeah and in the back you
see that's that's the big house and then
all that around there that's a bunch of
pastures and there's a big professional
race track that went around it and then
there's jumping arenas round pins all
kinds of stuff there that was a that was
a big farm
okay
yeah so uh so yeah so she thought she
heard all these horses galloping thought
they escaped but nobody else heard
anything so she's like okay whatever
but then David who's been out playing in
the woods
he got us riding up on his bike and he's
kind of wigged out and he said I was
just out in the woods and like I said
it's 300 acres there's nobody else
around and he's like he said that he
heard and he's grown up like on the show
like being interviewed and he said that
he heard like old-timey music he said it
sounded like a violin or something like
that like real like very distinctly and
he said it was really really creepy like
it creeped him out so much that he was
just like yeah [__] that and like rode
out of the woods and rode back to the
house and he told them about it but then
like I said his dad is just like wow
she's here and horses and you're hearing
old-timey music in the woods you guys
are crazy you know what I mean it's that
kind of [__] so he didn't really believe
what was anything that was going on he
thought they were just all losing their
marbles
so then apparently some weeks go by uh
Frisco the favorite horse uh stops
eating entirely and several other of the
horses get sick and all of the horses
are Joanne's because she's got like I
said she's got a bunch of her horses
there but she's also boarding a bunch of
others and she's like but it was just
hers that got sick she's like you'd
think if it was like a disease that all
the horses would have got it but they
didn't
so she calls a vet and the vet says well
maybe it's colic
like we'll do some tests like you know
and she's saying well maybe they're just
all stressed out because of you know
various things maybe they've been moved
around she's like yeah but you know
we've been keeping the horses all on the
same schedule it's like I don't know why
it would just be my horses and not
anybody else's because we do the same
[__] with them every day like nothing
has changed so that's like well I don't
know I'm out of ideas so we're just like
doing tests and we'll see how how it
goes and I think like at this point like
some of the students on the borders and
stuff like started to get kind of
nervous because even though the vet
seemed to think it was maybe just stress
related
um they were like well what if it's a
disease and like what if our horses
catch it and stuff like that so I think
like some of the students were starting
to think maybe I should go board my
horse somewhere else you know what I
mean
so then they kind of jump back into the
present day
um you know where Joanne and this and
shambhalak Sue are like walking around
the farm and uh Shambala Sue says well
maybe the horses were you know all
uneasy because all of the negative
energy that's like surrounding this Farm
or whatever
so then they jump back in time again
because like I said this is just a very
confusing uh timeline here
and they said um because they were
worried about the horses they installed
an intercom so they could be able to
hear the horses from inside the house
um and they said that Joanne had
actually gotten real close to a lot of
her students and to to a point where
like the students would like hang out at
her house like they'd play cards at
night and [__] like that
so one particular night they're all
sitting around playing cards and having
some wine or whatever and they hear the
horses out in the barn and they all seem
like they're kind of like unsettled you
know what I mean like they're making a
lot of noise and then they said they all
very distinctly heard a weird like they
said it sounded like a man whistling on
the reenactment it kind of sounded like
somebody playing a recorder that's what
I thought but they said that it sounded
like a man whistling like really loud
and like really distinctly
and so the students were like well is
that Jim and then he's like she's like
no Jim's out of town like on a job and
there's nobody else on the farm but us
so I don't know who the [__] that is
so basically her and the students were
like we better go out in the barn and
like chat because maybe there's somebody
in there you know what I mean because
all the horses are making noises and
stuff
so they all go out to the barn and then
there's kind of like a sequence where
they're all creeping around the barn and
it's like super creepy and here again is
they're creeping through the barn and
they very clearly show like a dude like
a ghost dude like in one of the Stalls
yeah but she didn't say she saw that she
said she felt like there was a presence
in the barn watching her but she didn't
say holy [__] I saw a ghost dude in the
state because you'd think that you would
yeah that's that's what I saw that's
what I was talking about right that's
why I say that
that dude's not even paying rent
just staying in the stall
is that you don't have to pay rent
anymore yeah you can just be like you
know that's right
he's not paying board
[__] out of stall he's like I'm just
invisible I'm just you know I mean I
just come out of storm I could clean the
waterbur
he's going down there and [__] pull
the clean clean that waterers out every
[__] day and then in that in that
Barn I just showed you that Barn had
these gigantic [__] Florida spiders
these big [__] hunting spiders
and [__] I'd open up the [__]
sliding doors to open up the stall doors
and those [__] spiders would be up in
the [__] tracks and they jump out
they [__] jump out of the [__]
truck and roller track I had one of them
land on me one time wow look at that
yeah it's another Tom hates better I
hate him no time I like spiders I saw
one going up a wall I come back there
and [__] every Dead coming to cat and
have two or three dead ones on the
ground because our barn can't catch him
at night
and I saw one got a wall in a [__]
bam I kicked it and it splattered and
went up and [__] hit me in the face
tarantula juice that's on you tarantula
juice tarantula juice you grabbing
[__] feed bags out of the feed room
and [__] hear them [__] [__]
hit the top of the feedback
huge [__] spiders hey spiders got a
huge fight yeah yeah there's a Mexican
Tarantula faster though big hunting
spiders
the body's the size of a mouse yeah
they're big guys and then the [__]
legs are that big
and they can run straight up a wall
[__] at full speed I went I went in
the bathroom at my grandfather's house a
long time ago and saw one just like
right hanging out by the towels
[Laughter]
couldn't wipe them out they were living
up in the room I don't mind them
couldn't get rid of them
I don't mind spiders I don't know a
cockroaches I don't like cockroaches but
I don't mind spiders and that Barn there
had a damn Handler's apartment in there
which was basically vacant
and a big storm was coming and I had to
[__] spin three days living in there
with them [__] spiders
remember that were they like crawling
all over no I was just afraid that they
were coming in yeah
when those all the [__] listen all
night [__] horses making all that
goddamn noise and then hurricane came
yeah because you got to be there
right hurricane comes you got to be
there because there's you can't just
stay at home you you got to take care of
these horses well yeah you know they're
worth a [__] tens of thousands of
dollars each one
and these people have entrusted you with
these days
can't access just put you guys on the
speakers at work everybody's loving the
show thank y'all we love you guys thank
you very much oh my God pressure but
Danny ruling said I could have sworn in
this episode that they heard ghostly
boots walking through the hallway but
maybe it was it well I think the kid
heard something like a little bit later
and then he also said the kids bike
crash in this episode wasn't even bad
enough to get a brush brush burn let
alone to fouled up back that's what I
thought too they must not have showed it
in the episode the way it really
happened because maybe they couldn't get
a stunt kid or whatever because yeah it
was like the kid was riding in like dirt
I'm like you'd think he wouldn't even
have scraped his knee or nothing holy
crap like I've wiped out on a bike like
on a road and like slid and it's got all
this get all the skin off my shins you
know what I mean and it's like that kid
there's no way you could have broken his
back just doing what they showed in the
show so it must have been like obviously
a lot worse because he apparently really
did break his back
so uh so yeah
so they go out to the barn like I said
she said she felt a presence but on the
show they showed like a little ghost
dude being like hello like kind of just
like popping out of the stable or
whatever and all this and all the horses
are like well there's ghosts in here you
know what I mean
um and at this point like the students
kind of start canceling on her because I
guess the place is like creeping them
out
and right around this time too she said
and like I said they just kind of like
glossed over this or they just went over
it really quick because she was kind of
checking in the stable and they showed
like something grabbed her leg she said
like an invisible hand I'm assuming
because at first they just kind of
showed a pant her pants like doing I'm
like what the [__] just happened well
later on that character said that
something did grab her yeah she did say
something grabbed her leg so it wasn't
something the trickery on the pet
you know on the part of the show I'm a
part of the show she said something grab
right yeah because I was glad they made
that distinction because I'm like
watching I'm like wait what did what
happened like because I couldn't really
see let me chop it off yeah because I
couldn't really see what it was it just
looked like her pant leg went kind of
funny and I was just like well okay
um but yeah she said something grabbed
her leg something invisible obviously
and the horse was kind of like flipping
out
and then at this point I guess this was
shortly after this happened then Jim
comes in it's like oh I brought new
lights because you know the ones that
before were [__] up and I'm gonna redo
it and she just like gets all pissed off
she's like I you know I have ghost [__]
to deal with right now it's like I don't
you know [__] that [__] you know that
he's like oh well excuse me I thought
you wanted the lights blah blah so there
was that now uh so again another night
I'm assuming this is a little bit later
and so like Jim is at work one night he
apparently like I said he was
electrician so I guess he worked on
building sites and stuff and sometimes
he was gone like all night or was out of
town or whatever
so
um Joanne decides that she's gonna call
an acupuncturist for the horses I'm like
there's horse acupuncturists I don't
know why I'm surprised by that but yeah
okay yeah so we got everything for him
that's what I'm yeah massage therapists
and everything I could see that more
than anything more than acupuncture but
you know what I mean whatever
I'm not sure if there's anything to it
no as far as the acupuncture thing well
that's what I mean I was like I could
see massage because that is yeah because
there is something helpful about that
but acupuncture I'm just kind of I think
the jury's still out on that massage
surgery
training
drugs those actually work I don't know
I've I've actually had
uh acupuncture done to myself after
motorcycle injuries but it was they not
only were they his name was Dr Thiago up
in up in Brazil not only did he stick
needles in there he also electrified him
so my [__] back was [__] shaking
you know from like the electromagnetic
pulses and everything
and that I think relaxed a lot of
tendons and muscles to help things go
back into place I don't know if just
needles would have done it right he was
using high-text electric yeah
electricity electrodes in there yeah
like some Frank and stuff yeah yeah and
after that I was like oh man it feels a
lot better you know so
maybe I should go see if somebody's got
some electrified needles because I'm
like terrible yeah it works I have like
horrible like a constant like ball of
stress like right here
lost but you have a tense muscle it'll
totally exhaust it and it just loosens
up
you know because it's just I don't even
remember what it feels like for that
muscle to be loose because it hasn't
been for like years and years because
I'm so used to like being tensed up
we'll send you to one of them massage
therapists well [__] Cole's massage
therapist I know I've thought about that
and she keeps saying it's like you know
why it's just cute I could give you she
might even get you a [__] happy
ending
because she I mean she yeah she has off
she's a massage she's a massage she's
done it
yeah yeah he is he's one too he's a
Jaguar yeah jaguar and Jack was on HRT
he's going he's doing [__] roids now
he's gonna be he saw me and he's like
dude I gotta do that he could [__]
get he goes you look [__] great and
then um so he's on and uh but now we
ought to have coal over and have coal
work you over
she's cute okay pretty probably about
what 40 now I can't I don't know she is
yeah yeah
the two of them are awesome she's got
kind of a goth chick yeah we saw him at
mannequins a few weeks ago that's that's
the last time we were talking to him
um but yeah so instead of the
acupuncturist comes over
and before any acupuncturing takes place
I'm guessing she comes in and says um
you know I'm not only an acupuncturist
I'm also I also have psychic abilities
yeah yeah because of course she does so
she comes over and she says yeah you got
a bunch of spirits in here it's like not
a good situation and Joanne was like
said she was very very happy to hear
that because I guess she felt like
Vindicated because I guess her husband's
in a Believer you know what I mean
um and the psychic is like yeah there's
like a whole cloud of negativity like
over the farm or whatever because all
the [__] ghosts you got here
now so later on and they kind of glossed
over this as well because I thought they
were gonna go more into like the history
of the land or whatever because they had
a scene where Joanne was on the phone
talking to um presume she was talking to
Jim they didn't really specify but she
was talking to him on the phone it's
like oh I've been doing some research
about the history of the land that we
live on it's like did you know like a
plague came through here and like killed
a whole bunch of people or something
like that and he's like oh wow that's
neat or whatever but then like they
didn't really mention that again I'm
like okay
so um so then later she goes to check on
the horses like she does every night and
while she's out there in the barn
evidently
David the son because I guess this is
kind of later at night so the kids
already in bed asleep and he hears
something
that wakes him up something that sounds
like somebody walking down the hallway
which I think was what Danny Rowling was
uh referring to earlier it sounded like
creaking like somebody was walking down
the hallway and so he it wakes him up
and he kind of like creeps out and like
looks out of the hallway but he doesn't
see anybody and then he gets back in bed
and then he said like the grown-up hymn
said he felt or he heard somebody
walking right by his bed and he said he
felt it too so I'm assuming he's felt
like the air of like somebody walking by
his bed and like he heard footsteps
and um like right walking right by him
in his room and obviously no one was
there so that like freaked him out
really bad so he just like starts
screaming for his mom but then his mom
runs in and you know he's like there was
somebody like walking by but obviously
you know so they tell Jim and you know
he's just like whatever you guys are
[__] nuts he doesn't believe it
um but then at this point uh Joanne just
like because I was like wow she's like
reading him the [__] riot act because
she's like look I'm gonna have this
[__] property cleansed so you know
because I'm sick of this [__] so you
just kind of take the kid and get him
out of here so we can sort this [__] out
and he's just like okay because she's
bad you know what I mean now sadly at
this part this bummed me out more than
anything but um I don't even know this
horse but I guess like Frisco was her
favorite horse and I guess the vet came
back and said oh the it had something
really wrong with it I don't remember
what they said was wrong with the horse
but they said um we can't do anything
for her
so they're gonna have to like put her
down right and that was like her
favorite horse and I was like oh man
that's a bummer that was like that was
the saddest thing the scariest thing
about this whole episode was that they
had to like put that horse down that was
like stuck but I apparently like all the
other horses were okay they didn't
mention anything else about the other
horses after that what was sad is I was
in I was in the industry around the
2008-2009 era
and all the owners went broke during the
economic collapse
and so many horses got put down for
financial reasons just because nobody
could pay board
and they couldn't go anywhere
and you couldn't give them away
and they had to make up excuses to put
horses down I mean that's [__] sad
sad sad
but they're created out of nothing
through an industry and sometimes when
there's too many of them they have to go
back into nothing
that like some people treat animals like
that no they love those animals but they
couldn't pay bored
and then you say well maybe I'll put it
out to pasture that all the pastors were
[__] filled nobody would wanted it
you know what I mean you couldn't give
them away
so what were they going to do just
starve
yeah you couldn't you couldn't feed them
you know what I mean there were times
where we'd love to have this horse
you know it's not ours it's a it's an
owner we'd love to have it so we keep it
but we can't afford to feed it
yeah because you got [__] so many of
them horses are expensive you know and
and you're like what are we gonna do
with you know and then vet shows up and
uh we got to do what we got to do and
[__] horse put down
totally fine perfect horse
that was 2008 2009 economic crash
it was heartbreaking
I don't know if I could yeah we'll see
because that's the thing when I was when
I was a little kid the one thing I
wanted to do like more than anything was
I want to be a veterinarian but then
like when I got older and I was like man
a large part of my job is going to be
like putting animals to sleep and I was
like I can't do that I can't yeah but I
mean perfectly fine young animals
nothing wrong with them beautiful
beautiful animals good disposition
highly trained owner broke couldn't give
the horse away what do you do yeah
everybody else has given horses away any
places that would take them are all full
just the entire horse industry was just
collapsing
and you know
the the
[__] banking industry didn't give a
[__] they still want their money you got
to pay yeah pay mortgage you know on the
[__] places and [__] it was [__]
heartbreaking they're just bad [__] that
happens
okay and it was just like some [__]
Tiger King [__] with a tiger King
killing them damn Tigers because he had
too many of them and couldn't afford
them
I kind of understand it because it was
happening in the horse industry but man
it's terrible to see yeah it's like I
just beautiful [__] tigers and big
cats who are [__] have good
relationships with human beings just
being shot because no one can afford to
support them
the only thing that makes me feel a
little bit better is that they came from
nothing they were from a breeding
program they're not from the wild they
had to return back to nothing
that's what I mean it's like they just
because they came just because oh if it
wasn't for us they wouldn't be here but
they're here now right that's still an
individual the thing is how much meat
they eat a day and you have well yeah
like I said and there wasn't many people
to pay that's why I kind of that kind of
the thing the whole Tiger King thing and
like all that kind of stuff I always
kind of feel like maybe if you don't
have a necessary reason to have like a
bunch of tigers or a bunch of horses or
something like that maybe just don't
don't create them but maybe just don't
yeah because like what if you go broke
at some point like you said and then
like you end up having to put them all
to sleep or so I mean just like [__]
just well the thing is is I always
thought those man those things were
[__] vicious and dangerous you know
what I mean [__] um and then you'd
hear about Romans keeping lions in their
houses and [__] yeah but then I I didn't
really believe it but then I see all
these videos coming out of Russia
where they let people own big cats and
they're just like any other house cat or
hat or dog just they have to have
certain standards they big fences so
they can't escape or anything
eventually it's gonna have to come to
part where if you want tigers and big
cats to exist in the world they're not
going to exist in the wild because their
habitat's [__]
not what it was
in the wild there's only going to be a
few thousand of them
if you want a cat population they're
gonna have to live in people's homes
which yeah there's nothing wrong with
that well I live in people's homes I
don't honestly that's why I don't have a
problem well okay I don't have a problem
with zoos if they're not like a zoo like
if it's like a if they have like a like
a breeding program and they actually
have habitat for the animals and stuff
like that you know like even something
like Animal Kingdom at you know Disney I
mean they they take care of all their
animals they have a lot of room for them
they have a breeding programs for ones
that are endangered and stuff like that
it's like I don't have a problem with
that because like I said you you know
you we wouldn't have those animals
anymore if we didn't help them out
there's a good Channel on YouTube called
I am Puma it's a Russian couple and they
have a mountain lion and they have a
cheetah and they have a you know good
little
little stalls for them and they're
allowed to just roam around and they
have big walls they can't escape and
uh they take it out for walks they got
put jackets on it and leashes and then
they get into bed with the dude and it's
obvious that these big cats just love
this guy you know who his daddy you know
and it's just that's their Pookie that's
the future of those big cats if you want
a big if you want big cats to exist in
the world they have to live in symbiosis
with humans
just like all the other animals like
dogs and cats and goldfish and all the
other domestic animals they're gonna
have to become kind of domesticated
which people love these animals nothing
wrong with that they're feeding them
yeah I mean as long as you know what
you're doing you're taking care of them
and then yeah and they have like a
reasonable life look at I am Puma that
[__] cat's loving it you know just as
happy as pookie
you know pokey's not escaping
Pookie's happy right in the house those
big cats are exactly the same
except when she gets mad at us for doing
something like a little bit wrong
like not holding the meat stick at the
proper angle for her to lick it those
big cats he's got are not de-fanked and
they're not declawed and I'd feel safe
around them because they grew up around
people
yeah I mean that's the thing I mean you
never know like an animal could turn on
you but on but a dog could turn on yeah
you know what I mean that's just the
risk you accept either your child
basically in this situation a human
child can turn on you well that's what I
was yeah yeah I mean yeah that's
happened before too so it's like you
never really
you know I I wouldn't I wouldn't advise
going out and like approaching them in
the wild that would be stupid but yeah
it's not the same situation right it's
not the same if you've like raised them
and they've been around people all their
lives and you don't generally perceive
people as food then maybe it's okay that
mountain lion gets in that it gets into
bed with that guy and curls up with him
and just puts his head on it it loves
that man yeah it's just a male
mountain lion you know he's like this is
my buddy
[Laughter]
Danny Rowling said zoos are prisons for
Animals yeah I do
um depending on what it is they used to
have I mean the same they're better than
they were the Sanford Zoo
um when I went there when I was a kid
and it was bad it was like all the [__]
was like really small and I was like man
this is a bummer but like I went there a
few years ago and it's much much better
and like I said I kind of feel like
nowadays
people have more awareness of it and so
it's like if you're going to build
something like that you really need to
replicate the animal's wild habitat as
closely as possible animals are far more
advanced than people a long time ago
thought yeah they're you can't just
stick a tiger in a little bitty cage
yeah with on a flat [__] concrete
concrete would like they used to do
[__] totally inhumane they didn't
think anything about it yeah well it's
just attack it'll be all right it's just
a Tiger It's not a person they don't
feel anything well they didn't really
seem to give much of a [__] about people
back then either to be honest with you
yeah it had pygmies in the zoo right
that's what I'm saying yeah so it's like
they you know they they didn't really
have a lot of uh sympathy or compassion
you can check that out they had anyone
who wasn't them you could go to the New
York Zoo back in the early 1900s they
had pygmies in there pygmy humans
yeah and I was like uh yeah it's a human
being like yeah okay
like you know what I mean it was just
like and the fact that they just did
that like whatever
[__] the good old look at that ladies
and gentlemen yeah no thanks they didn't
know [__] about [__] back then but yeah
but yeah
uh all right so where was I okay so I
only have this much of this okay
so uh so yeah so the horse had to be put
down that's how we got onto that topic
so Joanne gets some sage and starts
doing the thing you know like around the
sage
she said while she was doing that around
the farm she said that she had she heard
a whirlwind of voice she said called it
a whirlwind of voices and air that's
what she said okay so I guess I was like
okay fair enough coming on a psychic
attack I guess
um you know I'm sure they made it look a
lot more exciting on the show than it
actually was but she did say there was
like doors rattling and the horses were
freaking out and the lights were
swinging and flashing and [__] like that
so that went on for a little while while
she was siege and everything and then it
everything stopped suddenly she said
she's like oh well awesome I did it that
was easy you just light some sage and
then Bob's your uncle you know what I
mean
so uh then she says for a while after
that
things were normal
and they invested in like an arena the
they had part of their land I guess kind
of like you know torn up so they were
like in a building arenas for uh their
students like to train for uh
competitions and stuff
so a contractor had cleared some land
for it but the ghosts get pissed at all
the changes and I guess that's what one
of the psychics said to her too it's
like yeah you keep messing with their
land and it's like they're gonna get mad
and they're going to get all like
stirred up or whatever now not long
after Danny Rowling mentioned this
earlier uh the contractor goes bankrupt
and basically was like bye and like skip
town
so all the money that they had given him
up front because I presumed you had to
pay him a percentage uh he just took it
and uh left so they lost all their money
that they invested in the uh that they
were going to do with the arena
so uh I don't know what happened with
that because I don't think they brought
it up again
but
then they said the Sun
I guess the sun the sun David was like
doing some [__] and he suddenly this is
how he described it he said I felt like
I was in a barrel going to the bottom of
the ocean
yeah and then they had him like hearing
like a man's laugh like a man going like
laughing like also felt like he was
engulfed by a a deep Blackness yeah
something fear I don't remember what he
was doing at the time I forgot to write
it down
um what was he doing do we have any uh
commercials or anything we have to play
we're good no we're fine like I said I'm
almost done just uh reminding people
that super chats are active and so are
is super thanks the super thanks uh uh
feature is there if you're listening to
this show as recorded so um just passing
the collection played around gives Jenny
some money
yeah
so uh at this point like I said some of
Joanne's students had uh taken off
because they were creeped out by the
police but she got some new ones to come
over and she's like has them in the
house and they're like discussing terms
or whatever and then one of them
sees something in the house levitating I
think it was like wasn't it like a like
a radio battery or like a toy battery or
something like that it looked like a
battery pack type thing I'm not really
sure what it was but they said they saw
it like come up off the
counter and like levitate
and then it kind of like threw it across
the room so like some Poltergeist
activity so the students all saw that
and were like nope I'm out you know
never mind We're Not Gonna board here
because she got like [__] ghosts and
[__] so but that was pretty much the
only thing that
definitively moved that more that a lot
of people saw right I mean that I
remember yeah that's all I wrote down
anyway
what was that battery kind of like
floating it was a battery so it was
right okay yeah that's what I said I
think it was like about like a battery
pack yeah yeah like something that would
go like in a like a RC car or something
so then later that night Joanne like
after that had happened and after the
students like took off were like yeah
[__] this [__] creepy place she asked
Jim she's like can we please like call a
priest or something uh you know because
I can't really take it and I'm losing
all of my clients like I'm losing losing
all of my customers and my business
might go under
and Jim still doesn't believe her
however when they're both sitting there
like talking about it he said that he
heard well they both heard a kid's voice
like a little girl's voice
saying like Mommy and Daddy are like
calling Mommy and Daddy and they said
they both heard it very very distinctly
and I guess this kind of like tipped Jim
over into okay I believe you now you
know what I mean because it's like
there's no explanation for that because
there's no little girls on the property
they have a boy you know what I mean so
at that point he's like uh okay yeah you
can call the priest now
so a priest comes out and blesses the
house
and it actually does help for a bit
although Joanne said she still kind of
felt a presence or it still felt like
really oppressive or whatever
and at this point I think in the
timeline this is where the bike accident
happens that they showed way back at the
beginning of the show so I think this is
actually the point where it happened in
the actual timeline now
I think what it looked like what
happened was the kid was riding like I
said he was riding a dirt I don't know
what really happened because there's no
way you would break your back like just
falling in dirt like that but anyway
so he's riding his bike and then there
was they implied that there was some
kind of weird
negative energy thing and like one of
the horses kind of got flipped out and
like was kind of like rearing back or
whatever and then something out and then
I don't I don't know if demons like
tipped the bike over I don't know they
just like I said it was very vague
but whatever it was that happened the
kid fell off the bike and broke his back
and like I said so he had to go to the
hospital he did he's fine now like he he
did recover even though his back was
broken
um so basically then the shambolic Zoo
she says well I don't know if we're
gonna be able to muster up enough
vibrational energy I think that's what
she said uh to get rid of all of these
Spirits for good because there's all
this evil on the property it's a
spiritual Gateway or whatever
and so like after the kid got hurt
um they're kind of like okay well we
definitely have to do something about
this because this is getting dangerous
now so sue for some reason thinks that
this presence whatever it was like
escaped into the woods so okay
um and so sue is like I'm gonna go in
the woods and look for this I'm gonna
I'm gonna cleanse the [__] I'm gonna get
rid of this [__]
um so she goes out in the woods and they
have like a sequence where she's out
there like walking through the woods
like that and they kind of imply that
like all the ghosts are like coming at
her and she's like like that you know
what I mean so
and she said like later she said oh well
she's been doing this a while I guess
and she's like I've been stabbed by
ghosts and like choked and scratched and
stuff like that so I don't know how how
much of that is true
but so she tries to convince these
spirits to move on by basically telling
them you're no longer alive which you
know harsh
um you know please Ascend to a better
place
now apparently what she figured out was
that all of these spirits around the
woods including some kids and some
Native Americans and various other
people hanging out out there
um they want to go but something is
holding them back because you can't ever
just have like friendly like you know
non-interfering [__] Spirits you
always have to have one evil douchebag
Spirit that's like controlling all the
other ones and being an [__] about it
you know what I mean and that's what
happened in this situation also
uh there's this one Spirit named Samuel
who is keeping all the other ghosts
there somehow I'm not really sure how
all that works uh but there's always one
[__] isn't there in the in the Ghost
World
um apparently he did didn't he say leave
my slaves alone oh [__] I don't know so
he had it so he had all the ghosts got
me and I wrote that down so I'm guessing
that's what I was like I'm pretty sure
that's what I heard so I was like so
what's he so he's having all these other
ghosts do his laundry or what I don't I
don't know so he's like at I don't know
what a ghost would need slaves for but
yeah
just to talk to him just keep him coming
I guess but yeah so there's hoes that's
evident that's evidently the main thing
a high-end call girl that or [__]
male what they call them male companion
does most of the time it's just [__]
talking talking and listening like you
know you know
[__] dude in the industry was I was
listening to what he was saying
Seventeen hundred dollar an hour
call girl all right most of the time she
just yeah most times she's just being
taken out on some dude's yacht while he
[__] about his wife
I imagine a lot of the times it's
probably just it's just that yeah and
and which I don't know which would be
worse having to [__] the dude or having
to listen to it listening [__] about
this [__] wife that's that's that's
what that's what evidently was that's
that's a tough decision
so uh oh yeah poor baby
so girl girl the more the cost the more
like a uh of counselor like a therapist
like a therapist they are yeah I get it
yeah
I kind of suspected as much yeah
I mean you know but that's the thing
they but I I kind of feel like sometimes
those dudes like hire this like so
because they want to do like really
weird [__] up [__] like poop on your
chest or something maybe evidently [__]
like that Dubai's happening
um give you a clue but they pass them
around quite a bit there and it's porn
stars they're doing that too
the high high-end companions
are um there's a
um
evidently their most of the clients are
extremely wealthy or they're celebrities
so they just want discretion they just
don't want it to get out what's going on
right and then and the the the guy or
the girl that's doing this doesn't
really have a social media presence that
way they can go to parties and [__] and
people can't Google their faces and go
that's a hooker you know what I mean
it's that kind of [__] and they don't
really come from working class they're
at least middle class and they know
upper class ways
so they can handle themselves and mixed
in in higher Society Mixed companies
without giving it away that they're you
know not rich
that's that's a lot of it being an actor
or an actress
because they're taking them places like
ski resorts and [__] yeah and they can't
like they can't give it away that
they're there for hire
they can't be in there like you know
yeah picking their nose or right or
[__] freaking out over the cost or
something on a damn menu you know what I
mean holy [__] what are we doing yeah
yeah yeah
ways
yeah
is this sandwich gold-plated what the
[__] there's a good Channel called uh uh
Sterling Cooper and he's an ex-male
straight male companion who would hunt
whales it was mostly Chinese
millionaire women who were in marriages
that were like political marriages
and they'd take in places and uh mostly
it was just talking to them because they
couldn't trust anybody ever wanted money
from and
um he said that [__] he'd make a
contract for you know you know ten
thousand you know what I mean for the
week
and then she'd take him around she'd buy
[__] twenty thousand dollar earrings
and he's like I should have charged this
[__] more
but she's like hey man yeah I'm just
doing what I do
but uh prepared me that's your fault
wait he looked at it you know what I
mean it was uh he was charging him for
the time and for the experience but he
said the sex was free he's you know he
he said he would have done it anyway it
was just
he needed the expenses to get out there
with him and they had to foot the bill
and he had to role play and be people
that he wasn't because she's taking him
places right you know
Danny Rowling said there was a cop who
was just executed he wanted his wife to
[__] in his mouth and when she didn't he
had her killed what that seems a little
bit of an overreaction just a just a tad
I mean asking somebody to [__] in your
mouth that's kind of a big ask I mean I
know some people are into that I'm not
judging um you know it's gross but okay
um but
I mean I'm sure there are professionals
that will do that for you if you
if you like talk to your spouse about it
uh I don't even know what to make of
that I'm gonna have to like look that
[__] Robert uh frata f-r-a-t-t-a is that
what that says
I'm gonna have to look that up
I mean I'm sure it wasn't just I mean
I'm sure it was probably like a lot of
factors
um but that was just like the straw that
broke the camel's back I guess
this the straw that [__] in the camel's
mouth
oh my God
what a weird thing to kill somebody over
I mean I guess it's not the weirdest
thing I've heard but that's that's up
there is that that's up there there
but yeah so uh where were you oh yeah go
sleeves
um so so this ghost Samuel is like I
said he's there's always one [__] in
in The Ghost and Samuel is it in this
one so he's holding all the other
spirits
there somehow
and uh so they can't leave on this
property
and apparently while uh shambolic Sue
was trying to get rid of Samuel and they
had like a funny scene where she's like
struggling with like an invisible it's
like ah you know what I mean like they
have the ghosty person there so it
didn't look quite so silly but yeah so
she's like apparently battling with this
invisible
[__] ghost and uh so he she said that
he like pulled her on the neck and like
knocked her over like knocked her to the
ground or whatever and then but
basically so this is like a little
anticlimactic I thought because like all
that happened like there's like a couple
seconds of like you know human ghost uh
fisticuffs or whatever and then and then
like she gets pushed to the ground and
then she gets back up and she basically
all she has to do is like push the ghost
down and released all his negative
energy I'm like well [__] man who knew
that's all you had to do just push the
ghost to [__] down push him around on
the ground just like you would do to
like a little kid on the playground yeah
and then he's like oh
I've been here for hundreds of years but
now I'm like I'm all [__] one with
the universe now or whatever so yeah so
she she did it
that was it she just pushed the ghost
down the end yeah
[Laughter]
it's even funnier if she'd like kicked
him in the nuts like just for just for
good measure I kicked the ghost right in
the nuts and then like released all his
negative energy but it yeah so
uh after that they implied like I said
they didn't really say this they spell
it out but in the uh reenactment they
implied that when that happened like out
in the woods like the ghost fight or
whatever
um I guess Joanne was back at the house
or in the barn and she it implied that
like when the ghost got pushed down and
the negative energy like went into the
universe or whatever
um Joanne was like oh I felt like a big
blanket had been lifted off her or like
lifted off the property so it's almost
like oh she knew that that it had worked
you know what I mean even though it was
like far away I don't like I said that's
just kind of what they shouldn't think
um so basically after that it seemed
like everything went back to normal
right
it's difficult to say because then the
announcer comes in at the end he goes
and we'll never know
well yeah we want to leave it open like
you know just in case because it's
scarier like you're like well the [__]
might not be worrying about the [__]
afterwards yeah you might be worrying
about like you can't just push a ghost
down and he's just right [__]
I'm coming back pushing it goes down to
Hell I can only strengthen it to return
later
for your ass
yeah I mean that's probably why would
happen Jenny's like yeah okay
[Laughter]
just coming for your ass
that's the porn you gotta see that [__]
dramatically ass
with with it with a bunches and like
some extra syllables
and yeah and I'm so pretty sure like I
said everything kind of went back to
normal or did it
um and then the last sentence that I
wrote was Jim got a Mario stash okay I
just read at the bottom because I
thought I should mention that how long
were we on for
um an hour and 17 minutes it was
actually a pretty short show uh anything
else that we have to talk about I don't
think so that was the end of that
episode but because like I said it was
it's an okay episode but I really wish
they had just filmed it like they would
normally film it yeah chronological
order right like one they didn't really
give you a good sense of like when this
took place because they never told you
what year it was and they all and they
always do because I always write it down
but they didn't tell you when it took
place so I was just like Well when the
[__] is this even happening was this
like 20 years ago when was this I mean I
assume
I assume it was something like 10 15
years prior because the kid was 10 11 12
something like that and then he was like
in maybe in his 20s like when they
interviewed him so I'm you know whatever
it was like a decade or so
but they didn't really specify so
whatever
and I don't know why they made the
decision to
tell the story out of order like that
because usually they do like a build up
that's what makes it scary right it's
like oh well I'm not in a different
writer the light started flashing and
it's like you know that's how they
usually do it it's like little [__] and
then like it builds up and then all of a
sudden like a ghost pushed my kid off a
bike and broke his back you know what I
mean might have been a different
director for this episode that's what I
was thinking and it's like I said I
don't know if they just thought the
story wasn't exciting enough so they're
like well let's open with the with the
broken back we'll mix it around like an
imply that the ghost did it even though
they didn't really
lean into that they just kind of wanted
you to think that I think but they
didn't really want to say it outright
yeah I just they they were talking
around a lot of things you know what I
mean Danny Rowling said this episode was
very basic yeah well it was basically
confusing yeah and vague and I yeah I
didn't realize that and so I don't know
so you can't the the storytelling
actually in the center the story
structure kept throwing me out of the
story
like I was gonna wait hold on where's
the beginning of this story and then it
goes yeah that's what I was thinking too
I'm like wait when did this happen what
now yeah is this now is this there yeah
right yeah is this later is this in the
future who am I right what's going on
you know yeah it was like that
it was like that
uh Ben says I saw the menu last night it
was really good yeah I've been wanting
to see that actually
I'll get around to watching that oh
that's the one that people are all
coming down yeah and didn't weren't they
kill him and eating people
no I don't think so that was that horror
movie we saw uh no this this one's new
okay
the one that we saw was the one they
were killing and eating people well we
saw a couple different it was just like
we saw a trailer for that in the movies
yeah we saw a couple different ones like
that
but yeah this one's like pretty new
yeah Danny Rowling is talking about the
guy with the the [__] in the mouth
thing yeah he's like yeah she was gonna
divorce him so he hired Hitman I mean I
didn't hear that story I didn't either
he's like he's he said his name Robert
frata frata f-r-a-t-t-a
it must have been a different reason why
I did it well that's what I said I was
like I'm sure that wasn't the only
reason that was probably just like the
yeah just one of the things that they
wanted the Catalyst yeah they're trying
or they're just trying to make the story
more salacious
[__] in my mouth so I'm gonna kill you
freaky [__]
[__] my higher a whole [__] hit man
you nauseous a whole hit man a whole hit
man
[Laughter]
how dare you I had
you guys are knocking me off now I want
a shirt now I want a shirt that says I'm
gonna hire a whole hit man you
non-shitting [__] yeah I had to hold
porta potty set up and everything
oh my God we can't get two part of this
round hole because I'll start gagging if
I think about it too much
he's got it on a special diet
oh don't start yeah you don't start
please don't start I want to eat nothing
but cheddar cheese
and broccoli she's gonna have a hard
time [__] that's all she [__] you
make it solid
oh my God
yep I'm starting to get gagging I heard
that from Powers Howard Stern I had some
guys calling into Howard Stern some guy
says yeah when I was a teenager as a
dude who paid me to [__] the [__] in his
mouth yeah and [__] like a couple
days later
other dudes are calling [__] yeah and
then they started talking to me yeah I
lived I lived just a couple blocks over
you eat the cheese he goes yeah I'd eat
cheese and he [__] paid me 100 bucks
I'd eat a whole bunch of cheese and [__]
sit on a porta potty and [__] in his
mouth
[__] ridiculous man and [__]
Howard Stern goes only on a Howard Stern
Show would you find out that [__]
eating cheese makes good taste in Duty
I was [__] Laughing Man well I mean
you know that that might be some
information these days I can't imagine
the situation where you might have
something but you do he was a freaky old
dude now he's just never wasted freaky
old dude in his 60s with a [__] you
know [__] bald on his [__] top of
his head and [__] hair around about
with glasses he's like something out of
them
Breaking Bad it was like that he was
like out of his 60s who was [__]
paying teenage boys to do that
that was his thing
weird
some weird [__] like I said they got
some [__] weird mutant [__]
out there doing weird [__] yeah
I'm glad that that's not common I'd go
crazy if that was common you know what I
mean it'd go insane be like yeah I don't
imagine that imagine if you like this
everybody you know is doing something
weird
it's something different each one you're
like [__]
okay
well last few weeks you find out
somebody you knows does some weird [__]
I don't I don't have a problem with
weird [__] it's like but no but at that
level but gross [__] yeah yeah and you
know like I said on the whole I'm I'm a
big advocate of if everyone is
consenting and you're not hurting
anybody uh and you know whatever you do
in the privacy of your home that's
that's on you
and just you don't got to tell me about
it or not then but it's or send me
pictures but um what if you're dating
some girl you're making out with you oh
it's my new sweetheart man she's so
[__] sweet and innocent it turns out
she's eating her own vomit why you're
not around just weird [__] like that
right you know what I mean they're like
nah nah
nah
eats gross [__] vomits it up and then
drinks it up and then you know what I
mean it just weird [__] like that you
know I mean I'm glad that I don't live
in a world like that uh you kind of do
though but but I don't live in a world
like I don't think it sounds like please
don't tell me that don't tell me that
um well people do weird [__] I'm not
saying that I don't think it's as common
as yeah but people do do got the
prettiest girl in the world you [__]
love her turns out she eats her own
boogers when nobody's watching that kind
of weird [__] I imagine imagine a lot of
that actually I imagine a lot of people
probably yeah she's a Booger Eater
[__]
[Laughter]
oh it works out it's all right it'll be
all right I promise I don't do anything
gross like without you I know without
even hanging out with you [__]
[__] almost what 13 years probably 12
years maybe now I'm not gross I mean I'm
not any grosser than like an average now
you're pretty much I've been an average
[__] I don't do gross [__] you
shower every now and then every now and
then
every now and then
yeah anyway uh yeah Ben says look at the
testimony of the experts at the Albert
Fish murder trial if you're interested
in that sort of thing yeah we did a show
about uh yeah I don't know how much of
what he claimed to have done was true
though I mean yeah he some of it might
have been like Trio and then some of it
might have been a little fantasy base
yeah he told all kinds of stories that
was never um some porkies yeah that
never really materialized
um
well he ate that one little girl he said
I didn't rape her but I ate her you know
she cried when I told her I was gonna
eat her I don't believe that he didn't
rape her I think he raped her that
[__] was a sex maniac
um nothing he did is he said he found a
little black boy beat him to death he
was like a little five-year-old black
one beat him to death and and that
nobody noticed I don't believe that that
happened
uh remember when he said that yeah there
was nobody was ever found
um there's all kinds of [__] that he
claimed to have done
that when you understand how a fish was
he liked to magnify his own [__]
grossness
he got off on you being repelled and
repulsed by him so he would just make up
[__]
he would he did [__] but I think he also
made up [__] well that's the thing with
a lot of those types of uh
serial killers of people with those
pathologies is that yeah they do real
[__] up [__] but they imagine real
[__] up [__] too and a lot of times
they conflate the two things or they
just lie yeah because I think they kind
of well in a way like you said I think
they kind of get off on everyone
thinking they're monstrous like in some
ways so it's like they're like well I
did some real bad [__] but I'm gonna
like it embellish it to make it even
worse or like more disgusting they're in
captivity and they're getting off on the
reactions of the of the law enforcement
the investigators are talking yeah
because everyone's like horrified yeah
so they they run out of [__] real
crimes so they start making up new
crimes yeah to freak them out but
you can't trust them you have to have
physical evidence if their bodies aren't
there and they can't really pin down the
time or the date no nah
Ben said one of the psychiatrists
testified at the Albert Fish thing uh
that it was fairly common for people in
all walks of life to eat excrement I I
find that hard to believe this is
Victorian era they thought maybe they
were a bunch of [__] eaters back I don't
think they were I think what it is but I
don't know why they would be they were
getting off into that damn Freudian
psychology which is totally debunked
okay Freud was wrong about almost
everything
um
so they just assumed yeah that's gross
[__] people are probably doing it that's
just you know yeah yeah yeah people are
gross that's what they're doing now
these people are gross but they're not
that gross yeah that's not common that's
rare I've never met anybody that if it
was common me and Jenny would know about
it we know all those fetish
[__] yeah they wouldn't hide it
now I do no I don't know anybody
personally but I do know that there's a
it's not a big it's it's a small like
percentage of like the fetish thing that
are into like scat play that are pooping
so because I've been to fetish parties
where I didn't see anybody doing it live
but they did have like a lot of film of
it
that you could watch if you wanted to
that's not the mainstream population but
no but yeah like even the even in the
Federation that's kind of like yeah yeah
they're like yeah most of them are like
let's just go over here and get whipped
I'm really into that you know what I
mean the Spanish stuff is just group
stuff here come on man [__] let's
double team my wife that type of [__] or
uh let's get our wives to make out
[__] you know and then [__] then
we'll make out they do [__] like that
yeah I mean it's not and I kind of feel
like overwhelmingly it's almost
overwhelming like BDSM yeah yeah which
like I said which like I said nowadays
like is is pretty vanilla I feel like I
mean I think it was shocking back in the
day maybe a big element of it is fashion
what they're wearing yeah and how things
look so and the music
uh that that I think is some of the
biggest stuff but [__] man
we know this couple Brian abek
she's a an attorney and he's an ex-con
that she met
and uh that's a huge fetish couple there
and they're upper middle class I saw
them Saturday just saw them Saturday
and they're they're in their 50s
and they get girlfriends that live with
them for a while and uh all kinds of
they got little dungeons they have a
dungeon in their house and for a while a
teenage daughter was living in that same
situation but they kind of like had
little apartments up in the little rooms
you know they had a night real nice
house
and the daughter was just kind of
embarrassed by the parents
and she's like totally normal I feel
like teenagers are always Yeah by their
parents whatever their parents do
they're like yeah yeah and the
girlfriend's there and everything yeah
it's just uh yeah she was always just
kind of like nasty you know
it was fun old people oh yeah yeah it's
funny [__] old people doing like all
this [__] [__] yeah okay what's going
on I wonder what happened to her I
haven't seen it well she's old enough to
be long gone now well I know I don't
know I haven't seen her a long time
she's probably married now that was what
10 years ago
and she was probably 17 then
she's probably pushing 30. yeah she was
18 19. yeah then I don't know if it was
10 years ago but it was a while back
maybe eight it was a while back yeah but
yeah uh Danny rolling said at the end of
a scat party a scatplay party there's
always a brown jacket waiting for you
like golfers get up the PGA tour
so gross
it's just it's terrible like I said it's
I know people are into their own thing
and it's if you're not hurting anybody
fine but it's like don't tell me about
it and I don't want to hear about it one
of the weirdest things about fish
was just how masochistic he was but
that's that's pretty
unusual for a Serial murderer yeah
usually they're just sadists usually
just sadistic but he was masochistic he
would take all these damn needles and
stick him up in his Tate and these
things were [__] deep in him some of
them things were up in his bladder yeah
had worked their way he was filled with
[__] needles that he stuck up in
himself
he said and they had been in there for
years
yeah they have like you can see the
x-rays yeah
it's [__] up yeah
some messed up people in the world yeah
thankfully not many are as messed up as
that yeah but and he had a whole
religious element where he
wanted to experience Jesus's suffering
and he's the devil and Jesus combined
you know he's making people suffer but
then he suffers to save him out and just
say to masochism the same man Beth says
everyone needs a hobby
and what was weird is he was a little
old man
doing this
yeah a lot of it a little old man
harmless looking
little old man eating 10 year old girls
and [__]
it's like yeah I enjoy gardening and
stamp collecting and eating children and
sticking needles yeah and my instinct
would be man I'm gonna beat that dude to
death if I saw some [__] like that
but then I'd have to [__] pause on
this is whatever I do this guy's gonna
enjoy it yeah
you know yeah that's probably what he
wants because he was masochistic
and I was like well yeah the whole time
you'd be doing it he'd be like yeah more
and more yeah
you could do some to him like those
cartel dudes [__] I get videos from
Mexico [__] some of the [__] the
cartel dudes are doing
vivisecting a man alive and these they
got [__] blood plasma and all kinds
of [__] to keep him alive and there's
he's nothing but just a an exposed skull
and a rib cage with internal organs in
it though everything else is gone and
he's still alive
okay you could probably do that to
[__] Albert Fish and he'd love it so
what are you gonna do that's what I mean
you can't really do yeah
Ben says there was an utterly Infamous
criminal called Gary Webb here in
Victoria I've heard of that guy actually
who is a self-mutilator he cut pretty
much everything off while he was
imprisoned maybe we should do a show
about that dude I've heard of him but I
don't know that much about it cut
everything off of himself is that what
you're talking about yeah who was this
Gary Webb
write that down yeah because uh
like I said it's not you don't see it
much with serial killers serial killers
like I said are usually sadistic like
they want to take their thing out on
others you don't usually see an Albert
Fish situation where he's punishing
himself just as much which is I'm always
kind of interested in that psychology
yeah you know what I mean all right so
it's nine o'clock I probably gotta
start getting ready to wind down so I
can get up early again in the morning oh
Med said it was on the prison cameras
too okay well I'm gonna end up watching
yeah okay if we do a show about that I'm
gonna end up watching that sounds good
yeah that'll be good uh I'll put it in
the poll
in the next poll
so yeah so if you want to vote in the
polls by the way
um either go over and join us on patreon
or you can do a membership on YouTube
because I also post the polls on the
YouTube Community tab uh for members
only so you can vote on what we're going
to talk about and the show that we're
gonna that was a good segue wasn't I
don't even mean to do that
um the show we're gonna do on Wednesday
on the main show because I don't think
we're going to stream tomorrow because
I'm worn out and I need to take a break
but the show we're gonna do on Wednesday
I've been wanting to do this show for a
long time we're going to talk about
acquired Savant syndrome do you know
okay yeah you know what they call it
well they call it sudden genius syndrome
it's basically people who you get a head
injury and then suddenly you can do all
kind of yeah that's gonna be a good one
so yeah so um so I've been watching like
a couple I watched like a couple TED
talks about it and stuff like that like
today so I'm kind of like gearing up and
I've got like a couple papers printed
out about it that I want to read and uh
so yeah so that should be a good show so
it's gonna be on Wednesday what that guy
who was in the uh
project Stargate he was in the Army and
got shot in the K-pop which is a helmet
and then he started dreaming true after
that and they put him in that psychic
that psychic army unit to do remote
viewing
it would be like an acquired Savant
syndrome he couldn't do it until he got
shot in the head
that's some weird I didn't even realize
maybe I should save this for the show
but I didn't realize that I kind of
thought this would be like a little bit
of teaser I guess I kind of thought that
it's like oh well it wakes up something
in your brain it's not exactly waking
something up it's actually yeah more
like turning something off turn
something off which I think
yeah yeah yeah and like actually the Ted
Talk I was watching like with a
neurologist he was talking about that
yeah shuts off the inhibitor neurons
right so they just start firing like
crazy and then your Consciousness is
bigger than it was yeah yeah you're
aware of more yeah I mean yeah and we'll
get into like what because they don't
know a huge amount about it but they do
know like enough about it to sort of
simulate it a little bit like to a small
extent so which I thought was really
interesting so we'll get into that high
on LSD one time and watched him uh
watched um
on television some magicians and and uh
no magician could fool me when I was on
LSD I saw every trick and understood how
it was done
and that like from what I've been
reading and watching like that makes
complete sense yep
like what they think like why that works
yeah but yeah the restrictorship that
the alien overlord is installed yeah
that's what it is all right so yeah uh
be sure to come by Wednesday because
that should be a really cool show I
usually like to do stuff about like
weird psychology stuff like that so uh
so yeah so have a good rest of your
evening you guys thanks for dropping by
today and we will see you guys again on
Wednesday good night